Nobody doesn't love you.
Let me back up.
When we think of places you might find
life,
we typically think of the goldilocks
zone around a star where water would be
liquid in its natural state.
And if you get a little too close to the
star,
heat would evaporate the water and you
don't have it anymore.
It's gone.
Too far away would freeze.
And neither of those states of h two o
or are useful to life as we know it.
We need liquid water.
So you can establish this green zone,
this habitable zone,
this goldilocks zone,
where if you find a planet orbiting
there,
hey,
it's a good chance it could have liquid
water.
Let's look there first for life as we
know it.
Now it turns out that the source of heat
of course,
is traceable to the sun.
And if you go farther out,
everything would or should be frozen.
All other things being equal.
But you're Ropa a moon of Jupiter
sitting well outside of the goldilocks
zone is kept warm,
not from energy sources traceable to the
sun,
but from what we call the tidal forces
of Jupiter itself.
So Jupiter and surrounding moons are
actually pumping energy into Europa.
And how did you do that?
As you rope it orbits Jupiter,
it's shape changes.
It's not fundamentally different from
tides rising and falling on earth.
The shape of the water system of the
earth is responding to tidal forces of
the mood.
And when you do that to a solid object,
the solid object is,
is stressing.
And because of this,
a consequence of this is that you're
pumping energy into the object.
It is no different from when you say
anyone who's familiar with racket
sports,
indoor racket,
you could be a racket ball or squash.
You say,
let's warm up the ball before we start
playing.
You want to hit it around a few times.
You are literally warming up the ball.
It's not just simply let's get loose.
How you are distorting it every time you
smack it and then the resilience of the
ball pops it back into shape.
And every time you do that,
every smack your pumping energy into the
ball is not fundamentally different from
what's going on in orbit around Jupiter.
So you have this frozen world Europa
completely frozen on its surface,
but you look at,
you look at the surface and there cracks
in the ice,
there,
ridges in the ice where there's a crack
and it's shifted.
And then refroze.
So this Ridge has discontinuity in the
crack and then continues in another
place.
So what this tells you is that Europa
cannot be completely frozen because if
it were,
nothing would be moving.
You look at the surface of Europa,
the frozen surface,
they're like ice chunks that are like
shifted and refrozen and shifted again.
It looks just like if you fly over,
uh,
the,
the Arctic ocean fly over the Arctic
Ocean in the winter.
These are ice sheets that are breaking
and refreezing all the time.
It's the same signature as that.
So all of us are convinced that beneath
this icy surface is an ocean of liquid
water.
And there's no reason to think it
wouldn't have been liquid for billions
of years on earth where we find liquid
water,
we find life.
Yeah.
Wherever we find liquid water,
we find life even places like the Dead
Sea.
Why did anybody call it a Dead Sea?
Because the microscope hadn't yet been
invented.
And sure of the,
maybe there's no macroscopic vertebrate
fishes,
but microbes
have no problems thriving in practically
any conditions under which you would
find liquid water.
So what this means is not only do we
have a source of heat outside of the
goldilocks zone,
we have conditions under which life
could be thriving.
And knowing that this is possible has
completely broaden the net that we are
casting in search for life in the
universe.
No longer is it that,
let me,
let's find a 72 degree title pond and
see life forming there.
No life is pretty hardy and yeah,
if it takes liquid water,
we,
that may be the other place in the solar
system that is teaming with some form or
another of life.
So yeah,
we all want to go to your roper period.
Can we got to go ice fishing though?
Cause you've got to cut a hole or melt a
hole.
You got to get there somehow because
this sheet of ice by some estimates are
several kilometers thick.
And so it'll take some effort to get
through that,
which we haven't really fully figured
out yet.
But it's an engineering problem,
not a science problem.
So clever engineers should be able to
figure that one out.
And by the way,
you rope is not the only one of these
moons in the outer solar system that's
kept warm by the sort of title stress
forces.
There are other moons that feel the same
influx of energy.
So for example,
io,
that's the innermost moon of Jupiter
that suffers from this phenomenon even
more at that moon is so hot.
There are volcanoes erupting from
within.
There it is,
it is rendered Multan whatever solid
parts of that moon there are.
And so in fact,
the most volcanically active place in
the solar system is io,
one of the moons of Jupiter.
And we don't know how to sustain life
under temperatures that hot.
So,
but it's a reminder that if you're
looking for sources of energy,
we no longer need to be anchored to a
host star in our search for life in the
universe.
Mm.